you know what my big thing was my dad
had a piranha and I would feed a
goldfish that was my showing up yeah you
serious yeah we had a bunch of them he'd
go to the pet store once a week and he
would get these goldfish and you just
dropped them in it was [__] brutal
man like that job was just to get eaten
dude that must have been the talk of the
school yeah we're going to Billy's house
afterwards we got a bunch of goldfish
the [__] piranha if you put eight in
there that was it they were gone and the
thing would they would always try to
hide behind the air filter I remember
that thing like like a zillion miles an
hour like it's back tail it would
[__] dig its way in there dude in
that thing like a like a wood chipper
just [__] eat them and then it would
be so full of fish its belly would get
extra that reddish orange and it would
just be sitting at the bottom of the
tank and my mother would talk to it be
like Charlie look at you look what you
did
you're a bad boy Charlie